Many of you have been holding off on buying
the budget $329 iPad because of rumors of
new 2019 iPads coming soon, and now, they’re
finally here, the 2019 iPad Mini 5 for $400
and 2019 iPad Air for $500.
The new Mini may not be that bad of a deal,
but the new Air is extremely underwhelming,
and anyone looking for a new budget iPad should
not buy it.
I repeat, don’t buy the 2019 iPad Air.
I’ll give you all my personal recommendation
on what to buy in just a minute.
Ultimately, it’s a handicapped version of
the 2017 10.5” iPad Pro.
It’s using the same chassis, display resolution,
battery, Apple Pencil support, and more, but
although it seems like it’s just as good,
it’s missing some very important components
of the Pro.
So here are 5 things that are lacking compared
to the 10.5” iPad Pro.
The first two have to do with the display.
First of all, the display brightness is limited
to 500 nits instead of the Pros 600 nits,
so it’s quite a bit dimmer and it doesn’t
support HDR video, even though it supports
P3 wide color gamut.
Secondly, it doesn’t support ProMotion,
which is the one thing that made the iPad
Pro so great.
It basically doubles the screens refresh rate
to 120hz so every swipe and animation is buttery
smooth.
Trust me, this makes a massive difference
in day-to-day use.
Not only that, but ProMotion also significantly
reduces Apple Pencil input lag, making it
seem like you’re drawing on actual paper.
The new Air really misses out big by lacking
ProMotion.
The third thing isn’t that big of a deal
for an iPad, but it still sucks.
The rear camera is only 8MP compared to 12
on the iPad Pro, so you don’t get 4K video
recording or 1080P at 60, and picture quality
is gonna be worse as well.
For the 4th thing, the new iPad Air only has
one set of speakers on the bottom compared
to four speakers on the 10.5” Pro.
The speakers were both louder and the stereo
sound in landscape mode was amazing compared
to the old 2-speaker setup.
All in all, the new air is just lacking way
too much for me to be able to recommend it.
Yes, it’s got an A12 processor that’s
more powerful than the A10X, but to completely
honest, it was already tough to notice the
difference between the A10X and the A12X in
the new iPad Pro, at least in day-to-day use.
The A10X in the 10.5” Pro can run basically
any app or game currently available on the
market, so the A12 doesn’t make that big
of a difference.
Now you might be saying, of course, the Pro
is better, that’s why it’s called the
Pro.
Well, in reality, Apple was selling it for
$650, only $150 more than the new Air, and
it was definitely worth it, just for the ProMotion
technology alone.
Unfortunately, Apple took it off their website
this morning, as soon as the new Air was available,
and we all know why.
Now here’s the good news, you can easily
find a used 10.5” iPad Pro for under $500,
or refurbished models on Amazon with prime
shipping for only $434.
You can even get a brand new one on sale for
only $570 on Amazon.
So that’s my recommendation.
if you’re thinking of getting the new Air,
don’t.
Buy a used 10.5” Pro instead.
You’ll be much more happy with it.
Now if you’re not looking to spend that
much money, the 2018 iPad for $329 is still
the best deal for an iPad ever.
It’s good enough for almost everyone and
I still recommend it for anyone that isn’t
looking to buy the new 2018 iPad Pro.
Even better, I’ve seen it on sale on Amazon
for as little as $250 brand new.
You simply can’t beat that value.
Now let’s say you’ve been waiting a while
and you really want a new iPad, but can’t
afford the new Pro.
Well, the new iPad Mini actually isn’t a
bad deal.
It’s got everything the new Air has, but
with a smaller display for $100 less.
But it’s really meant to be in a market
of its own, for those who want that smaller
display and portability.
I honestly still recommend going for the budget
2018 iPad unless you’re buying the new 2018
iPad Pro.
If you haven’t seen our 1-year review of
the 2018 iPad, click the card above or click
the end screen button at the end of this video.
We’ve already ordered both of the new 2019
iPads so we’re gonna be doing in-depth comparison
videos soon, so if you’re not already subscribed,
make sure to do so now!
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video.